are you struggling with irritile
dysfunction or aim potency
facing these issues can take a toll on a
man's confidence and self-esteem even
affecting his mental well-being well if
you are looking for a natural and
effective solution to these problems
you're in luck welcome to match
simplified where we simplify men's
health for you today we are driving to
the extraordinary benefits of pumpkin
seeds for Men's Health
pumpkin seeds may be small but they pack
a powerful punch when it comes to
addressing many of the common issues
faced by men
we all know that men's sexual health is
something we can't ignore today we're
going to address some of these problems
that can have a huge impact on a man's
confidence and quality of life we'll
talk about the science of pumpkin seeds
and how they can be a vital food
supplement when it comes to male sexual
health so without further Ado let's get
started
let's first talk about why pumpkin seeds
are beneficial for erectile dysfunction
erectile dysfunction might be more
common than you think for instance a
study published in the Journal of sexual
medicine found that erectile dysfunction
affected around 26 percent of men under
the age of 40. pumpkin seeds have been
considered an aphrodisiac by many
cultures including Greeks Romans ancient
Asian and American civilizations
throughout history they were
traditionally used in various Herbal
Remedies and natural aphrodisiac
preparations providing a natural
solution to men seeking improved sexual
function now let's get into the science
part and look at few of these compounds
president pumpkin seeds that effectively
act as an erectile dysfunction remedy
the most important and abundantly
available amino acids in pumpkin seeds
are Arginine and aspartate to understand
why arginine is important for erection
you have to understand the basic
mechanism of penile erection let me
simplify this for you during normal
conditions the penis remains flaccid
because the smooth muscles present in
the shaft of penis remain constricted
and the blood flow to these smooth
muscles is low when the penis is
stimulated the smooth muscles relax
opening up the spaces between them and
allowing blood to flow in and fill these
Open Spaces in short the penile erection
is controlled by the widening and
narrowing of the blood vessels the
constriction and dilation of the blood
vessels is in turn controlled by various
chemical Messengers released in the body
one among them being nitric oxide nitric
oxide is basically released by the inner
lining of blood vessels and it is a very
potent vasodilator meaning it leads to
the dilation of blood vessels which
increases the blood flow to a particular
area of the body
nitric oxide has a significant role in
the physiology of penis acting as one of
the most important chemicals that leads
to a proper erection
Studies have demonstrated that changes
in the release of nitric oxide are a
known Factor contributing to different
types of eritile dysfunction
now coming back to the importance of
arginine present in the pumpkin seeds
and its relation with nitric oxide
basically nitric oxide is produced in
the body when arginine is converted to
citrulline therefore pumpkin seed
consumption boosts the Arginine levels
in the body which then promotes
increased nitric oxide release when the
penis is stimulated the nitric oxide
dilates the blood vessels present in the
smooth muscles of phenyl shaft which
leads to a proper and sustained erection
another great Amino Acid found in
pumpkin seeds is aspartate also known as
aspartic acid aspartic acid is found
naturally in our testes and the
pituitary gland at these sites aspartic
acid regulates the synthesis and release
of two important hormones utilizing
hormone and testosterone which are key
hormones responsible for the erectile
function of penis
therefore consumption of pumpkin seeds
enriches aspartate in our body which
increases the levels of luteinizing
hormone and testosterone this has been
proven to improve the penile activity
and the erectile response
another set of molecules found in
pumpkin seeds that help with penile
function are phenolic compounds like
hydroxypenzoic acid caffeic acid ferulic
acid and vanillic acid these compounds
inhibit an enzyme known as
phosphodiesterase 5 or pde5 for short
pde5 enzyme basically breaks down the
nitric oxide in our blood vessels when
these phenolic compounds present in
pumpkin seeds inhibit this enzyme the
nitric oxide doesn't get broken down and
this leads to increased availability of
nitric oxide in the penile blood vessels
which leads to improved erectile
activity
so these were some mechanisms by which
pumpkin seeds drastically help patients
with erectile dysfunction another big
issue that can be solved with regular
consumption of pumpkin seeds are
prostate problems in men including
benign prostatic hyperplasia and even
prostate cancer
recently pumpkin seeds have entered the
spotlight for treating benign prostatic
hyperplasia and consequently prostatic
cancer also in a study done in Germany
by Dr Martin librand 60 patients with
benign prostatic hyperplasia were asked
to consume pumpkin seed extract once a
day for 12 weeks
surprisingly within a span of three
weeks patients begin to experience a
relief in prostate enlargement related
symptoms and by the end of 12 weeks
around 30 percent of their symptoms were
reduced the enzyme five Alpha reductase
is present in your liver skin and
prostate this enzyme converts some of
the testosterone you produce into
dihydrotestosterone
dihydrotestosterone plays an important
role in the growth of prostate and
ultimately leads to prostate enlargement
pumpkin seeds inhibit this enzyme which
decreases the amount of
dihydrotestosterone your body produces
this effect of pumpkin seeds is
basically responsible for their positive
impact on prostate enlargement also
known as benign prostatic hyperplasia
while researching this topic I came
across a very interesting study in which
the effects of pumpkin seeds were
compared to tamsolution and FDA approved
drug for prostate enlargement even
though the drug proved to be far more
effective in managing prostate
enlargement symptoms pumpkin seeds
proved to achieve close to similar
results but with no side effects
patients who received temp solution in
the study experienced dizziness
headaches and retrograde ejaculation
whereas those who consume pumpkin seeds
experienced no side effects this could
be considered a win-win situation for
prostate enlargement patients consuming
pumpkin seeds along with their
prescribed treatment could effectively
help them Target their prostate problems
through multiple ways without fearing
potential side effects
before we move ahead with the video I
just wanted to take your few seconds to
share a message about our patreon page I
want to express my sincere gratitude for
your incredible support and enthusiasm
for math simplified it's because of you
our dedicated subscribers that we can
continue spreading knowledge about
Health Fitness and diet running a
YouTube channel like met simplify takes
a lot of time effort and resources from
researching the latest medical
breakthroughs to creating engaging and
informative content we strive to bring
you the highest quality videos and this
is where I would like to humbly ask for
your support by making a small donation
on our patreon page you can directly
contribute to the growth and
sustainability of Med simplified your
support will enable us to expand our
team enhance our production quality and
increase our reach to cover even more
topics that matter to you every dollar
counts and your generosity will go a
long way in helping us create more
valuable content for you and The Wider
Community as a token of our appreciation
patreon offers exclusive perks to our
valued customers such as Early Access to
videos behind the scenes content and the
opportunity to suggest topics for our
future videos you can find the link to
our patreon page in the description
below moving ahead let's talk about how
pumpkin seeds can help in increasing
sperm count and sperm motility in males
the previous two beneficial effects that
we discussed were mainly focused on the
Aging male population rather than young
adults in reality though the sexually
active generation have far more to gain
from pumpkin seeds pumpkin seeds have
long been studied for their role in
improving sperm count libido and sperm
motility
it is a known fact that low zinc levels
in the body often lead to infertility
and decrease sperm count in males the
effectiveness of pumpkin seeds in
treating impotency is largely attributed
to the rich content of zinc magnesium
and selenium present in them these
minerals especially zinc and magnesium
stimulate enhance and contribute
significantly towards better and
increased worm production in males it
should not come as a surprise that
pumpkin seeds are listed among the top
10 foods that are rich in zinc and
magnesium also remember we discussed
earlier in the video that amino acids
found in pumpkin seeds stimulate the
release of luteinizing hormone and
testosterone in the body
adequate levels of these hormones are
essential for proper sperm production in
males
pumpkin seeds are also a very good
source of omega-3 fatty acids
particularly alpha linolenic acid alpha
linolinic acid is a essential fatty acid
that body cannot produce on its own so
it must be obtained through the diet
Studies have shown that consuming
omega-3 fatty acids can improve sperm
quality and motility and can also help
to reduce inflammation in the body
inflammation has been linked to a range
of reproductive problems including
erectile dysfunction and low sperm count
the American Heart Association
recommends having at least 30 grams of
pumpkin seeds every day as a part of a
healthy diet one easy way to include
these amazing seeds in your diet is to
have them roasted you can also add these
seeds to salads smoothies and other
dishes for added nutrition
I will also include some links in the
description that talk about specific
recipes around pumpkin seeds so make
sure to check them out
in conclusion pumpkin seeds are a rich
source of many important nutrients that
are essential for male reproductive
Health these nutrients including zinc
magnesium and omega-3 fatty acids play a
critical role in the development and
function of the male reproductive system
and may also help reduce inflammation
and improve prostate health
incorporating pumpkin seeds into your
diet is an easy and delicious way to
support your reproductive health and
overall well-being
have a great time crunching on these
delicious seeds I'll see you again in
another amazing video follow us for more
and consider supporting us on patreon
that's it from us at meds simplified
have a great